other than what was available there for
construction purposes was no heavy
equipment so people literally using
shovels and using you know their hands
in some cases just to kind of dig to try
to pull out the survivors we have
stories after stories of people
literally there's one man was sitting
holding the hand of his child he can
reach her hand but they can't pull her
out there's no heavy equipment so he
kept hearing her voice until she passed
away so this was the child now the
fathers can they can actually touch he
was holding his head and calming her
down telling her we'll bring you out
you'll be okay and then they couldn't
because they don't have heavy equipment
now who was the person that tweeted this
that they don't deserve the daughter of
the president of Syria she tweeted that
those people in the north they are
terrorists they don't deserve to live so
they're young I'm paraphrasing the young
girl her father was holding her hand
she's a terrorist that's basically what
the brainwashing of people within within
the government controlled yes absolutely